she firefights in the block and get to
children look no but but actually while
roughly standing up so in the in in the
context in the in the spirit of stories
I know that's my bet you need that so
2002 I think I go to crypto conference I
go to conference and then you know we
tell and we say okay let me but might be
a you're on hostile becomes also so what
we go for three day hiking in the
mountains before crypto so we are we
plan we do the reservation to do stuff
and then urine comes down from the
airport for the FM you wait for him in
in LA and this this young guy comes with
him said I brought my student with me I
hope you don't mind
wait so so they then become and then
this student I read this you see paper
and and it's sat bugging me for the
whole day three day trip about you know
things that don't work and this this
global state and stuff and I you know
and read the or three there withdrew the
whole three days and you know and then
you understand if you know and then you
know I could even join three days but in
the the worst part of it
that he was right but then there were
papers written left several years after
that
thank you Ron it was a I thought you
were talking about the different story
in the same trip there in the parking
lot okay so I'm going to talk about
consensus through hoarding and this is a
joint work with the Hubbard Chen and
Elaine shape so let me briefly review
what we're talking about you all know
what consensus is now but just to make
sure we have the same terminology so we
have a set of notes they would like to
agree on an ever-growing set of
transactions a clear ledger and we
require two properties consistency
meaning that any of these two notes
roughly should see the same view of the
ledger and liveness means that whenever
somebody wants to add some transaction
it should be added and also sufficiently
fast so as you all know by now at this
point of the workshop consensus has lots
of different names what I mean by or
lots of different meanings but what I
mean by it is just state machine
application and what today is more
commonly known in the blogging community
as a permission block chain that really
is all the same thing all right so a
little bit more precisely let's go over
these two properties of consistency
alertness so we said these nodes would
like to agree on this ever-growing list
of transactions also known as a ledger
write and consistency has says two
things the first thing is that at any
given point if I look at any two nodes
it should be the case that either my
tree my ledger is a prefix of yours or
vice versa that's what means that we
agree maybe you have seen some more
transactions I haven't caught up yet but
at least whatever I have is a prefix of
yours but presumably I will catch up
very shortly and the second thing which
is also very important is that actually
I am consistent with myself in the
future so my current ledger is always a
prefix of my ledger in the future so
whatever I've written there should
always remain so that's consistency and
liveness says that whenever some honest
guy sees some transaction either because
he gets it as an input or he sees it
from somebody else it should appear in
his ledger sufficiently soon in
particular if you and I have some
disagreement your ledger is longer than
mine that means that eventually it will
get added to my light roll so right now
I'm not talking about transaction as a
Bitcoin this is just like some messages
in that case these things will always
get added you can always on top of this
like prune things that are invalid in
some sense but this is just like a way
to alert you of messages everything is a
considered valid it's just the easiest
abstraction to the document so this
notion of liveness I consider here that
says that whenever somebody sees
something it should get added to the
ledger sufficiently soon it's a very
strong notion of liveness and to achieve
it you need to consider a synchronous
model computation because otherwise if
message can be delayed forever you can
never hope to make sure that everybody
sees that transaction so we're going to
be working in this synchronous model of
communication in particular I'm going to
talk about a model called the diffusion
model where the protocol is going to
proceed in some fixed rounds fixed time
steps just like in a synchronous case
and whenever somebody wants to send a
message they're going to diffuse it over
the network and it will arrive at
everybody within some fixed Delta time
this is an upper bound on the time it
takes for the message to arrive so by
now you're pretty used to this model
you've seen it in lots of talks
yesterday this is the model that Bitcoin
is analyzed in and we're going to be
using the same one another thing that's
important to note that we're going to
consider a model where all messages or
authenticated so whenever you send
something I know it's coming from
when the adversary sent something yes so
here we're assuming that even if no
matter who's sensei good guy or
adversary it always the relative in
Delta so you can relax the model to
assume it only holds for all these
players but its loss of generality
because you can always add some echo
protocols to ensure that it arrives at
that also when the good bad guy does it
if our if our fake point-to-point yeah
okay well point-to-point also requires
authentication if you need to know who
it comes with a point but a point with
authentication yes sure yeah but right
now I'm gonna in order to talk about I'm
gonna talk about communication you mean
point-to-point
this I told me point-to-point because
I'm gonna be talking about communication
efficiency that's gonna be the main
thing I'm gonna be talking about and so
I'm interested in how many message I
need to send on is diffusion channel so
I'm sending a message that gets sent out
to everybody so the photographs I will
be discussing later on is going to be
used a PGI so we have signatures so
really you know yeah whenever you send a
message you know it comes for themselves
you can I'm just saying like this is the
the cleanest model this is the way a bit
crazy you can add it to it I'm gonna be
only focusing on this simplest case the
attacker is I'm gonna consider an
attacker that yes he sees the messages
and he can actually control the
scheduling of the messages so and he can
delay it by delta so the attacker is
controlling the network whenever you
want to send a message he decides when
to deliver it within Delta steps very
good point thank you all right so just
to make sure that we understand this
consistency aliveness in the scenario
just like like Ron talked about the
reason we really care about
today about consensus and these two
properties is that any consensus
protocol really allows us to implement a
global public Ledger's really think of
this as having some Facebook or let's
say where you can post messages and
everybody who wants to look at this
thing will see a consistent view it
won't be fully fully consistent but it
will be consistent with the plus minus
some Delta time so what I mean by that
is think of having this idol
functionality where whenever somebody
wants add a message it will get written
to it within Delta time and whenever
somebody wants to read it you will see
what's currently written there plus
minus time Delta all right so maybe run
us to look at it and he will see what
was written up till time 11 and 27 and
the Dahlia looks and she will get 11 28
but it's very close to what's written it
so we don't think we on the sequence so
we will agree in a sequence but we also
have it really is like I'm looking at at
the sky this thing has been written in
the sky but we might see slightly
different angles but so it's plus minus
this little Delta time fully written
thing on it but we might see like what
was written at different times plus
minus Delta so in particular if you wait
another five minutes you will get to see
what he saw for sure yes but it's a
little bit stronger than just traffic
list because I also know that when if I
see something at 11:28
when you look at it 11:30 you will also
seen it because it's so that's the
that's what these two things capias it's
a very strong strong and natural thing
all right so what what's known in in
this classical model well all these
classically the results that you've
heard about already boot camp probably
today so we can achieve a consensus
assuming less than one third being
corrupt and that's also necessary and in
the PKI model if you also have a syrup
or everybody has a public secret key you
can actually achieve even up to n minus
one corruption so you can do much better
and additionally in the speaker model
you can achieve something has a very
nice likeness property that transactions
actually get confirmed and expected
constant number of rounds if you go up
to and over to corrupted layers okay so
that's in the kind of classic results
from story from the Aries and let me
carry over the high level approach that
this type of the consensus protocol are
constructed because it's going to be
useful for from you later on and it's a
it's a very very simple recipe so we're
going to proceed in rounds or in epics
in each epoch we're going to pick some
leader this leader is going to bundle
together a bunch of transactions into a
block okay and then he's going to send
out this block to everybody and then
we're going to run what's called
basing agreement protocol or or
multi-value agreement protocol in order
to agree on this block that we saw the
same thing if you run this agree in
protocol and we did so the same thing
then we have we can make sure that we
add this block to ledger and we're all
done lot of details and definitions
where are you going well we'll get there
okay if you don't need route me maybe I
get there all right so what is the
visited arguing protocol you've seen it
before also let me go over it again so
in a Byzantine agreein protocol we have
a set of players and you can really
think of it as a single short consensus
okay so we have these players they all
have some inputs and and they can run
the protocol and eventually produce an
output what we require is that any two
honest guys should get the same output
that's what agreement says the wrongest
protocol any tonus guys should really
always get the same output the protocol
should terminate fast and eventually
what we also want is this non-reality
property that if everybody starts off
having
same input then that is out place you
get if all the good guys start off
having say we put then they all should
produce that output if you go back to
this consensus construction from a from
a bi protocol if the leader proposes a
block and sends the same block to
everybody then when they run the
business today given protocol they
indeed all have the same input and
therefore they will confirm that lock
and get that as an output okay so if we
have a Byzantine agreement protocol then
we directly get the consensus protocol
using this simple approach okay so we
just go in different rounds we have
different leaders in every round the
leader prepares a block sends out
everybody and then we run business
agreement to make sure he indeed was
honest and sent out the same block to
everybody alright so now to the topic of
this talk so in today's world we would
like to run this consensus protocol and
logical setting right so so Bitcoin
enables running consensus among millions
of nodes and in order to do this we need
to have a protocol fair to be speaking
that scales well with the number of
players and what I mean by scale well I
wanted to scalpel logarithmic Li with a
number of players
the urgent protocol is don't do that in
fact they grow linearly the
communication complexity is linear in
the number of players but nakamoto's
boxing protocol actually does it's the
first protocol for consensus that scales
Paulo growth weekly with the number of
players so that's an awesome feature but
of course it relies in proof of work and
which is not desirable for many
different reasons
so it doesn't solve specific issue
papers
what no it does it does I'll discuss it
later on like remotest protocol does
indeed solve this problem exactly so let
me go over a little bit more formula or
what I mean by a communication efficient
protocols so I want a protocol that
satisfies two properties the first one
is that the total number of bits that
I'm sending on this diffusion channel
should be small in particular it should
grow poor algorithmically in the number
of players and linearly in the length of
transactions in a security perimeter
okay so if you want to conform a log of
a million transactions you want this
communication complexity to be a million
times
polar gate making number place and the
second thing that you want is that
whenever you want like to confirm some
transaction it should get confirmed in
time let's pull the poly logarithmic in
number players also you can't afford to
wait for a billion runs four million
runs if you have a million players okay
these two public mixers that's the
notion of communication efficiency that
we're after
and indeed nakamoto's protocol satisfies
this so now the first thing in my task
is actually sure the original particles
don't satisfy it but really this should
be a trivial way to make them satisfied
all right why don't we just simply sub
select a small committee among all the
notes a committee of a size per log and
the fraction of good notes is going to
actually remain roughly same by a
tournament and then we just run the
protocol among those that committee
so what's wrong with this
infinite legend of okay sure the short
part isn't tired okay doctor yeah so I'm
not so worried about today this is
inferior although this is gonna mean
theater so that is nothing sure I have
yeah no no answering yes this is yeah go
yeah selecting committee selected
committee itself is not trivial but if
you have some set up if you have a guy
some kind of common reference drink sure
but like selecting committee it says
maybe to do it once after all thoughts
about yeah so yeah so this is the issue
that like once you know who the
committee is it's very easy if an
attacker to just crap the whole
committee and port Logan is a very small
number so if I know who if it's a you
five guys doing this thing I just
cropped you guys now it is true this is
works if you consider static attacker
that decides who to corrupt ahead of
time before the committee selected but
once the colibri if the attacker can
corrupt people after knowing who the
committee is than your dad so that's
what this approach doesn't work okay so
really to make this question non-trivial
we need to consider also adaptive
security nice we want a communication
efficient protocol that also is secure
the satisfies common consistency
alertness even when attacker can
adaptively corrupt the players
throughout execution so he sees message
protocol running and then he sees who's
in the committee and he gets to corrupt
them at that point also to do with the
complexity of
of selecting the committee because of
course with you I will select committee
I'd go on I mean I'm not committees from
well we exactly will discuss all around
very shortly because I'll go on is a way
to try to it's how to select the
committee in order to make it very hard
to get to craft it yeah okay so the main
question we're discussing today is can
we achieve communication efficient
consensus with adaptive security right
so that's the the main problem and
before I tell you what's known about
this thing let me just point out that
one could also discuss the related
problem just giving visiting agreement
which was a single-shot consensus and in
fact that has actually recently been
solved so there are protocols are
communication efficient and adapt to
secure for Byzantine agreement and now
what you might ask yourself okay if we
solve busines greement she'll be trivial
to go to consensus we saw this previous
recipe right just do this effort based
thing leaders and something else done
business agreement the point is that
recipe actually does not preserve well
it preserves either features your
adaptive security blossom preserve both
if you select the leaders at random then
once I know that you're the leader
I can I can corrupt you and mess things
up so it's not gonna be enough to secure
if you do some kind of round-robin based
things then you actually preserve
adaptive security but it's not going to
have it's not gonna be communication
efficient because you need to iterate
through a lot of leaders will get a bit
con in the this slide here okay all
right so what's known about this so far
okay remember we're all talking about
communication fishes an adaptive
security the first result achieved both
of those things was
nakamoto's protocol and one could
analyze it and show that indeed it
satisfies adaptive security also
nakamoto protocol trivially services
complication fish you see but also the
analysis that you heard some about yes
indeed actually shows also the strong
form of adaptive security okay and even
if you set the parameters correctly even
if the tackler controls the left and
left and half of the other guys yeah so
that's the first result but we said is
reduces proof-of-work and then we had
the beautiful
Algren result that came along by chen
McCallie
and they also managed to achieve
communication efficiency an adaptive
security system without proof of work so
they achieve a consensus protocol in the
setting that that were the same but
their protocol relied on a strong
feature of the model something called
erasers so they show a protocol if you
assume that honest players can erase
state perfectly and I'll discuss a
little bit more what what is a ratio
means but it's the ratio model it's it's
well understood in the crypto community
it's actually very hard abstraction to
obtain it's not easy to erase your state
you know in a way that is impossible to
recover so ideally we would like to have
a protocol in the standard model we
don't make any of these like kind of
trusted assumptions okay and that's the
goal with with our work but before I go
to to our work and how we achieve this
let me explain how either proof of work
or ratios overcome this issue that we
had with sub-selection
because it's very instructive to see
what problem is dealing with
so the first problem we have we had with
sub selection of sub selecting a
committee is that it's important to make
sure that I cannot a priori predict
who's going to be on the committee right
if I know you're gonna be the leader in
round 10
I should just corrupt you right so it's
very important cannot predict who is
going to be the leader to speak and with
proof of works like Ryan was asking
nobody knows who's gonna be elected
leader alright in proof of work the way
you're elect leaders is you're asking
people to find some puzzle solution and
a puzzle solution is some data such that
a random Oracle ID to the current chain
and the new block and the puzzle is
something smaller than D right so
everybody tries to find this puzzle
solution and nobody knows it's going to
find it right it's completely random and
attacker has no clue if it's going to be
you or you of you right so up you're
predicting is not possible so that's a
great feature of this type of proof work
based schemes now how did Al Quran and
Chen McCauley get around this thing the
very clever idea of using something
called a verifiable random function so
what's a verifiable on the function it's
a pseudo random function that has the
property that only the person who has
the the secret key actually can evaluate
it but once I evaluated it anybody can
check that answer is correct so think of
it as a private way to evaluating kind
of a random Oracle but a later one can
be verified now what they did was more
or less trying to kind of replace the
random Oracle here with the vrf and I'm
gonna do this leader based leader
election where I'm going to say that you
are a leader in some round J if when you
apply the very F to the RAM number J it
becomes smaller than some difficulty so
I'm going to elect you leader at random
if when you apply the vrf to the wrong
number you get some good result and note
that only you can do this so you can
predict in what runs you're gonna be the
leader
but nobody else can do it so this is a
great way for recovering this a priori
prediction problem everybody knows on
their own when they're going to be
leaders but and then later on when their
leader they can present this evidence of
it because they give the output and
everybody can check that indeed their
leader but we don't know ahead of time
who is going to be later
all right so this is great this prevents
this simpler type of attack of like a
priori predicting wisdom alizarin
corrupted him but we have a more serious
attack actually which is that when the
leader has spoken why don't they just
grab him after that right like when you
send a message then I know for sure you
were the committee so in some sense I
need to be able to also have to prevent
the fact that I cannot posteriori
corrupt summary and that seems much
harder now let's see what how that is
overcoming these two solutions so
actually with proof-of-work just the
fact that you were the leader you spoke
if I corrupt you after a fact doesn't
help me at all
and the point here is that just because
you mind the blog it is not going to
make you more likely to mine the next
block right
you were lucky now but that doesn't mean
it gonna be more lucky and its relies on
the fact that this election of who is
leader is tied to actual message or
something right it typed the block here
something whether you'd elected leader
depends on that particular message
now how do you do it with V refs now
it's more tricky because once you will
select a leader then you're the leader
all right it's not it was only based on
the wrong number and this is how so the
way Jeremy Kelly get around this thing
is by using erasers they say before I'm
going to send the message I'm actually
gonna delete my secret key okay so I was
elected leader great I'm King but I
produced a message gonna send but before
sending it let me also erase all my
secret kids that will needed to create
this message and then I'm gonna use
something called a forward secure
signature scheme that makes sure that I
will be able to sign things in the
future but nothing's in the past and
since I erased the key for the past if
someone comes and corrupts me after sent
a message I don't have anything that
allows me to to be more powerful than
anybody else it's very elegant idea I
was saying look let's just erase the
thing that made me King and then if
someone corrupts me after I'm speaking
I'm no longer king right they don't have
the keys anymore
so now as I mentioned the problem with
the ratios is not easy to do it always
there is also a problem with this that
has been pointed out in literature
previously is that also it's not clear
why people actually should erase it
because if keeping this key is valuable
because an attacker can corrupt you and
make use of you why should i erase it
it's actually worth something for me
so maybe I'm stupid to erase it right so
an honest like an incentive driven guy
maybe shouldn't even erase it so yeah so
so the question is how do we remove
these erasers okay and the natural
approach would be to say look we learned
something for Bitcoin right what made
Bitcoin work here was that actually who
was elected was tied to the message
right I applied the random Oracle to the
actual message I'm sending and that was
a key to make sure that whenever I send
something fun in some something else
that doesn't you know corrupting you
first after you send something doesn't
make you more likely to be allowed to
send something else so can we do it here
why don't we just apply the vrf not only
to the round number but also the message
I want to send
anyone
grinding exactly right there is actually
a reason why Bitcoin relies on this
assumption of that computational work is
limited right if I applied the vrf not
only to the run number but also to the
message an attacker could try lots of
different messages and get a much higher
probability of getting elected where's
the good guys you lit try one thing the
bad guy can try lots of different
messages so if I apply the vrf not just
to the wrong number but also to the
message the good guys in each round they
will apply it once but attacker he can
try lots of different messages he can
maybe rerun demises thing and therefore
get approached not sure how to make that
work because like how do you I don't
know yeah different keys you can not try
because you you only have one secret key
like you have vrf all you devi ref
commit like the vrf to public key
committed a single secret key CDF is
deterministic that is the property of
the very few cannot apply the VF to you
cannot get many different outlets the
graph that's indeed the crucial security
popular Veera
so here we can if you're unlucky you can
select no if the leader leaves the
system then that means like he's a bad
leader and eventually find another one
that's good that's like it a ricin yes
sure
exactly yeah yeah so this is we're gonna
keep keep picking leaders unless until
we get someone who's good and then the
brokers credit yeah thanks for the
question all right okay so our main
result is that we can actually achieve
communication efficiency without the
ratios understand that standard
assumptions in fact we don't even use
random Oracle's with the public key and
a common reference strings to assume
there is a a random string that's not
selected and standard cryptographic
assumptions with sub-exponential
security in typed mates I might explain
why we need some expensive security but
the key point here is but not block the
dissemination of your message no yes so
after I have sent out a message that's a
very good point that was slim I would
talk about that and but the model were
considering because we have paper
showing a lower bond that you have to
after a good guy sent a message if the
attacker corrupts him he cannot withdraw
that message a percent so just the open
question that remains after all this
great work is can you do a sub quadratic
visiting agreement against the fully
adaptive no because there is a lower
bond right discuss it later but yeah
yeah okay
so I'll probably won't have that much
time to go over the whole approach but
at least let me go over the high level
so the high level of the approach is to
in fact define a new notion of a
signature consensus but stronger than
Byzantine agreement they said Byzantine
agreement
didn't quite work well to compose like
this with leaders so instead we defined
something called a batch agreement
protocol and this notion a batch
agreement protocol will actually turn
out to compositor very nicely that would
be very easily composed nicely and then
the key thing is to construct this batch
agreement protocol from something called
hoarding and I'll describe what holding
is it's a it's a beautiful well this
guy's short you realize okay the key
point here is that using herding you
know the constructive step of a
consensus protocol is something will
allow us to use actually this message
based election we'll be able to allow
using a vrf applied to not just a wrong
number but also the message without
suffering this grinding attacks
so the United to all talked about that
shortly this is a guy called Banerjee
who just got a Nobel Prize last week so
it's a it's an economist and this was
his probably most celebrated work on
hoarding so I'll tell you about this
noble president work very shortly with
this grinding thing when everybody knows
the yes well problem with this is when
you tie it to the message is that people
can just try many different messages to
make sure that they get elected a bigger
greater probability no because like I if
I'm trying to get on the committee let's
say that I'm supposed to send some
signature on something I can just try
many different like to change one bit
here and there and just to make sure I
get electoral are gets on you secret so
in later rounds if you become leader it
will be able to corrupt you we're
talking about Al ground or the VRA the
vrf is essentially given the secret and
if somebody knows you secret can can
imitate you or not if somebody knows
you're sick if you're very rough yes
they can imitate you yeah but the point
that when you get corrupt in a
particular round that it doesn't make
you more likely to do we elect a leader
in other runs in future than anybody
else a lot of money
[Music]
again it's pretty high so right now I'm
not an improver stick to studying it's
just normal
okay so the another thing I want to
point out there is we are so more only
one-third or corrupted similar to
tolerant know so I'll tell you what the
budget definition is now it's very
similar to start a business the
agreement with one little tweak so much
agreement now thanks run for our left
but he explains to you a university
composability so it's the definition
that's kind of similar to to that so you
have players players are going to be
receiving some transactions from some
environments transactions coming in over
time through players ok and they're
creating their view of whatever
transactions they see at some point the
environments going to say start and then
they start on a protocol and it ran the
way today they produce some output so
the first what we have agreement is just
as before everybody on earth should
agree on output ii think termination
just before it should terminate fast and
now it is the validity requirement which
is slightly different
remember validity said before that
everybody had the same input then your
output the same thing now I'm gonna have
a much stronger validity requirement
this validity requirement says that all
the transactions that were received
long before the beginning of the
protocol long before the start message
was sent so in particular what I call t
0 mean - delay will delays and fix time
they should always be included in the
output so any transaction that everybody
saw long ago must be included in the
output
no no that's we'll discuss it watch and
it's still open to get 1/2 we think my
should be able to do it but it becomes
much more messy so we kind of didn't do
it yet I'm not quite sure exactly what
relationship is but look it seems very
like less than maybe some time this has
been considered before it's a very
natural definition just as whatever you
have received up until you know long
before the beginning of protocol
everybody needs included okay and the
ledger this is a single-shot thing a
battery is a block of transaction a
batch is it's almost the same that's
more like the next slide says that's
exactly difference once you have batch
agreement you can get consensus trevally
you just run batch agree with one and
then once you're done with that you run
in a second batch agree with it just run
sequentially that's the only thing a
consensus protocol always we can agree
to disagree it doesn't matter replace my
consensus
exactly
yeah yeah exactly the reason we want
some tonight this is that when a good
guys see something all the good guys
will exceed it within delay time and
therefore they will all have it and they
should enjoy that yeah
and so this is really why this once you
have this single-shot think and three
Billy get consensus we could just run
the protocol degree from that block then
run the next one we're not talking about
transactions here just as a ledger of
messages okay yes all right
so now let me get you to two holding
this is hurting is this very beautiful
phenomena that was observed in the
economic literature by this economist
called
Bridget Banerjee who as I said he just
got the Nobel Prize last week and what
he was considering this was actually
during his ph.d he wrote this work it's
look at the following problem so we all
get some beliefs about some event so
let's say it does smoking caused cancer
is some event w and let's say we all get
some independent signals about this
event and let's assume that all these
signals are equally strong okay so
everybody gets some belief be I this is
the signal and I know that bi equals to
the true state of the world with
probability let's say 3/4 well 1/2 plus
Epsilon
now we do know that if everybody just
announced their guesses and then we took
the average we would get a very very
good prediction of what the true said of
all this that's something known as the
wisdom of the crowds right so it's great
everybody announces at the same time
we'll get a will be able to determine to
say the word very very well but then he
said the following in the real world
that's not how things go people instead
announce their opinion one after another
of them right so we got to consider a
game where I'm gonna announce my belief
and my utility is high if I make a
correct guess and low if you make an
incorrect guess so I would like to guess
correctly true that the world and then
Ellie goes and then Stefan goes and so
on so forth okay and everybody sees what
everyone else did before that so what
you do first okay let's say Stefan
starts what should he do he should
clearly output his guests right IRA's
our very own information
he should guess whatever his belief was
bi so guess one equals to V one all
right then le goes okay what should le
do he's seen his own belief be two he's
also seen Stefan's guess g1 okay but you
know these are the two bits of
information he might as well trust his
own thing more than Stefan's so he's
gonna value his own belief stronger and
therefore it's also gonna output his
guess he's a big belief so guess two is
going to be equal to b2 okay this
actually requires a little bit of an
argument
it requires relying on the fact that
Ellie thinks that Stephanie's is
rational but the right thing to do is of
course just output your bit now let's
say I'm the third one what should I do
let's say that both alien Stefan
actually said zero they don't believe
smoking causes cancer
okay me on the other hand the evidence
I've seen the articles I've seen say the
smoking does cause cancer okay what
should I do I want to win if I believe
that you guys are rational then and the
net assumption I also believe that your
bits were zero so your signals were zero
so therefore if these signals are
independent the way I view it is look I
have seen three signals to go four zero
one go for one easy I should go with
zero so my signal actually is completely
uninformative at this point
and what about the next guy same thing
he does zero also and so everybody else
continues doing zero and we get
something called an information cascade
and even though we had this very strong
signal everybody just says zero zero
zero zero zero so this has more recently
used to describe the spread of fake news
even if I know better if lots of my
friends are like posting an article I'm
going to post a Tulsa because I think
that you know they must know something I
don't know and then I just copy that
thing and we just get a crazy thing
spreading in social networks has lots of
very important interesting consequences
okay and what's also very important here
to notice that these cascades actually
happen with very high probability high
probability almost with probability one
this cascades will happen okay and with
probability one half will cascade on the
wrong thing with high probability will
cascade on the on the wrong thing so
that's terrible you would think and you
get something you know what could be
called the foolishness of crowds even
though we're having strong signals we
still all say the wrong thing so a
little bit more precisely what you can
show then it's like if you assume
College personality that everybody's
Russia everybody knows that everybody
knows everyone knows that everybody is
rational then the right thing to do is
that I'm going to guess the most popular
bit that I've seen so far by combining
my initial belief and the number of
votes have seen so what I should do is
that I look at my initial belief and
very valued something and I see how many
votes this the other two bits have and
I'm gonna look at what's most popular
combining it to and I'm gonna do that
and then you see of course that like
once you have a majority for one we're
just going to continue cascading so
that's terrible but for us that's great
because we're trying to achieve
consensus we don't care about truth or
[Music]
truth or false here we just care about
agreeing right
for us we that's all we want
so let me explain how we get a batch
agree in protocol using this holding
approach and idea is actually yeah
because you're using hurting do you have
to assume that the rationale yeah this
was just holding uses rationality we're
going to assume Byzantine attackers
right but we're going to use the holding
protocol and we're going to show that
herding is actually a robust also for
Byzantine attackers and not only that it
will also get you this nice adapted for
her property all right so I'm finishing
button another why I started this yeah
okay yes I'll take five minutes in I'm
gonna have to run to my flight so this
is that particular go
just like in herding everybody is gonna
score where the need to vote on
transactions right and they're gonna
compute a score for each transaction
right its block of transactions and the
way you compute the score is they have
some initial scope think of this as an
initial plea for the transaction and
they will add on third the number of
votes that tells transaction has
received from other players and that's
going to be the actual score at the
moment and then in every round if I'm
elected leader I'm gonna be voting and
then I'm going to vote for the the most
popular transaction I've seen so far
okay so just like in the holding a vote
for more popular choice if I'm allowed
to vote now so we're running the holding
exactly as herding except with this
tweak that we need to also decide
what order to use detective players in
hurting you have like people go one by
one so the way we're gonna decide
whether you are eligible to vote is
we're going to use a similar trick to
algorithm using a PRF but now we can
apply the very rough not only to the
round number but also to the transaction
so now we're going to use this
transaction based voting so look at the
transaction and around and apply the vrf
if that is small then I'm allowed to
vote very good so for now let's look
think of it as a as a concatenation but
indeed in the actual proof it's going to
be important that you have it down to
something small so maybe all the time
maybe not okay so the important thing
here is we do this transaction specific
eligibility and this is indeed what
prevents this a posterior corruption but
so the fact that I can corrupt you now
that doesn't make you more likely to be
allowed to vote or anything else because
vote eligibilities transaction specific
now I haven't told you how to do this
initial score no everybody sees
difference they take second and they go
to vote for yeah you only run the V ref
what you're asking about this grinding
thing for some bizarre reason this
protocol actually is not I'll discuss it
very quickly but grinding cannot be done
on this thing for some magical reasons
okay
but before doing that let me just
explain the how to do the initial score
because that's the most interesting
thing so right now what we said was we
combining some initial belief with the
number of votes but I didn't tell you
how to form your initial belief so how
would I form my initial belief I'm going
to compute an age of a set of
transactions the age is the time since
what is the the latest transaction that
I have seen that's not included in this
block now if there exists if this block
is emitting some variable transaction
than I trade this is real
it's a bad block it's an old block and
the way I'm gonna score things now is
going to be something that is some
constant that's exponential decay in
terms of H so blocks that have small H
they're very young they contain all
transactions they're going to get a high
score but if you're emitting a lot of
transactions that I've seen I'm going to
give you a very low score and the
decrease is very fast and the reason may
be in what actually function is doesn't
really matter but the two properties I
want to this function is the following
any two honest guys the initial
transactions that they have are going to
be scored very similarly in fact any for
any set of transactions any two on the
skies will score them very very closely
because they have roughly the same age
from this case so that's important on
this guys are consistent in the scoring
and the second thing is that the actual
set of transactions that I have
currently seen I'm gonna score it very
high because as H 0 contains everything
so I'm going to score it high that's
number one
but something that emits a lot of
transactions is this exponential
decaying it's going to be scored very
low
so things that omit all transactions
things that the the batch agreement
should never output it's going to get a
very low score and now I don't have time
to really go over the proof but the key
point here is that since everybody good
the guys vote consistently will make
sure to have a lot of votes for
something yet things that have a bad
score a bad initial score will never get
votes from good guys good guys will
never vote from any bad transactions
because they have very small initial
score so even if you get too many bad
guys votes on it you will never bring it
up to to be high enough so I do this
very fast now sorry because I don't have
time so but you can give a proof that
this satisfies both validity an
agreement and it works the proof is
actually realized on this the proof of
this relies on this convergence
opportunity proof that you have
discussed before that when you
standardize nakamoto's protocol and look
more in the paper
let me just towards and just address
this question grinding and it's going to
be very high level now because I didn't
incorporate proof but the point of this
proof is that in the proof we're going
to be relying on Cherno pants a lot and
will show that certain things hold for a
certain transaction with high
probability of the tournament so we'll
show in fact that there is no with high
probability
there is no bad transaction that can
compete with the one that's being output
that will get many votes
okay maybe let's just say so the way
their argument goes is like I'm gonna
say let's assume for contradiction there
are two transactions that could get a
lot of votes T X and T X Prime and then
I'm going to say that's not going to be
possible because with high probability
the total number of votes you can get
for both T and X prime is bounded by
some 4/3 K and at least one transaction
is going to get 2/3 K so both cannot get
to Turkey so any fixed set of
transactions I know with high
probability not both can win okay and
therefore we conclude that one of them
is there there's only one that can be
output okay now the issue here is you
have this grinding that maybe I can find
some transaction that's gonna allow the
attacker to get many votes all right
that's the maybe that ii can search for
these transactions that allows him to
get many many votes both opportunities
now we're going to be using the fact
that actually transactions get a hash
down to something small so the actual
set of hash down transactions is a small
number of bits let's say K over 2 bits
but the Chernoff bound is going to be
holding except with probability 2/3
minus K so the cella plan holds accepted
very very high probability except it's
very very high probability so except
it's very very small probability the
number of votes you can get on any
transaction is going to be roughly
two-thirds K okay so even if you
enumerate all possible transaction even
if you could do grinding and go over all
of them you will not find one for which
it's shown up and kind of fails and
that's the way you get around this
grinding that even with Asics River
doesn't matter even if you go over all
transactions it does not allow you to to
break this protocol and I'm sorry this
is vague because they have time to go
the proof but at least maybe this
conveys an intuition of why chronics
parantha so the solution the grinding is
basically make the search phase very
small such that you cannot like
yeah exactly yeah so basic is going to
be using kind of a Union bond overall
possibility that needs to prove to
everyone so yeah so it's Polly low
communication in the diffusion model
this is exactly like a Bitcoin right
it's Polly log messages in the diffusion
center setting yeah so the common
reference ring is to select it's after
it's